With the recent spike in Titan sightings
circulating on social media,
proactive preparation for a
Titan emergence event is crucial.
A single towering force of nature
has the potential to forever alter
the lives of millions.
It is our mission to help you
prepare for that force.
The Titan Preparedness Plan is your guide
to staying safe in the face of monsters.
These are the three steps
you need to know.
1. Know Before You Go
Identify the location of your nearest
Titan shelter and practice navigating
a Titan evacuation route with your
family on a weekly basis.
2. Run and Take Cover
In the case of a Titan emergence,
calmly sprint to the nearest Titan shelter.
If your designated shelter is
inaccessible or at capacity,
seek the basement or lowest floor
of a nearby building.
3. Stay Informed
Follow any further instruction
from local authorities
and stay informed using your
mobile device, television, or radio.
We can't stop a Titan emergence,
but we can safeguard our lives.
Join us in building a safer,
more resilient community.
We are here to protect you.